so I decided to just turn the camera on
and just like see what would happen
that's kind of the hardest part about
making videos is you don't know what to
talk about
it's not a lot to talk about because
I've pretty much I can't stop turning in
this chair so I've been traveling just
took me a crazy amount and in my travels
it's very interesting because you're
hopping from playing to playing you're
meeting new people you're going through
TSA and they're touching you all
inappropriately which is it's their job
and I usually opt out of the back
scatter scans because I don't want
thyroid cancer so thank you Dr Oz for
that note going through TSA is such a
freaking nightmare especially for
somebody who travels with a lot of
electronics now the bad part is the bag
that I actually have all of my Gadgets
in it's a bag that charges all of your
electronics you plug the suitcase into
the wall and it has batteries inside of
it plug in your suitcase no this isn't a
sponsored video this is a battery this
is what I do with your TSA like what is
that is it the bomb no
my bad charges itself it's not only the
question why I have cameras and audio
equipment what are you doing who are you
what are you doing why do you have all
this crap I make YouTube videos I say
and then I want to know what's in a bag
is it a bomb is it a bomb is it a bomb
no it's not yeah with the gloves on and
then they just start feeling my bag up
they're just feeling it up they're
feeling it up and they take a little
sticky things
in the machine because one time I was so
scared because I thought for sure I was
gonna end up in some sort of jail
because right before I went to the
airport genius idea I went shooting with
big massive guns that residue is is on
me and I didn't get a shower or anything
before I went to the airport I just went
shot the weapons went to the airport you
wanna see that video it's right there if
they take that little
won't start like brushing it in my hair
they're gonna be like you're terrorist
like no I swear to you look at my
Facebook page I've got pictures of me
shooting guns and that's probably not
going to make things any better because
they're gonna be like what crazy person
goes shoots guns goes to the airport me
this girl so TSA does this thing for
those of you guys if you if you don't
fly too frequently you can opt out of
getting the x-ray scanners where they
scan you and they see all your parts
which they say they don't really see
them but come on let's be real just
seeing my parts five of the option to go
through metal detector or scanner I'm
sorry
let's go this way you're gonna have to
go through the scare like what is it
because you want to see do you want to
see what's under there almost like no no
no so I opt out and then there's one
woman just let me just assume the
position you stand like this and they're
like we're gonna go up here back of the
hands back up the hands then they go
shh and this woman
hold on she karate chopped me
girl you're gonna have to back up you're
just chronic chopped me in the no no
I am also
but it's really it's really it's kind of
hard to not be a slob and when you're
traveling for an entire month let's be
real one let me just take you for a
little room tour okay all right welcome
welcome to my home this is uh this is
the entrance way here we go it's great
it's real nice got this great painting
here by Edwin Edwin is a great artist
another thing that is so hard to do when
you're on the road is eat healthy when
you're on set though
went to the grocery store
We've Got Juice We Got Roots all of the
things and I got some straws I attempted
to iron today some of you guys also
requested to do a what's in my travel
makeup bag that's not this video
I shall take you into my bedroom we've
got some lights this is my suitcase
how can one person possibly wear all of
these well you know I don't know this is
what you guys look like
got you on this
got you on this dude
that's a little bit of my traveling
experiences about you guys what happens
when you guys travel and not even just
travel like what kind of crazy stories
do you have because I'm pretty sure at
least one of you guys have a good story
and if you don't well I don't know see
you guys later bye
foreign